- Do you think I could
pull off dark academia?
- Mm, no.
(wrong buzzer beeps)
- What about cottagecore?
- We are not doing this again.
- Fine.
Maybe you like me, haven't found
your perfect aesthetic yet.
- Or maybe you got a new job
or you've hit that summer in your twenties
or you have eight different
weddings to go to.
- For whatever reason,
you want a whole new wardrobe
and you want it right now, no problem.
You can open up a new Shein
tab or hit your local H&M
and walk out with 10 different
outfits for under 200 bucks.
- That seems better
than spending thousands
of dollars you don't
have on designer clothes.
But what happens to that closet
full of new outfits a year from now?
What about in a month?
(upbeat music)
- Critics of fast fashion
have long detailed
the industry's environmental costs
and unsavory labor practices,
but Americans still spend an average
of $1,700 per year on cheap new clothes.
So how did fashion start cycling
through our wardrobes
and our wallets so fast?
- As recently as the 1980s,
most fashion brands brought out
new collections two to four times a year,
giving consumers new pieces to buy
with the changing of the seasons.
The average American
bought about 12 new pieces
of clothing annually.
- But in order to increase their profits
clothing companies wanted to figure out
how to get shoppers to buy more.
They figured out two
reliable ways to do that,
lower prices and more options.
By the early two thousands
fashion brands like Zara, H&M,
and Forever 21 figured out
that they could increase the demand
for new clothing items
by making more of them.
Instead of coming out
with clothes twice a year
they were putting new items
on their retail floors every two weeks.
- And the cheaper the items
the more comfortable shoppers would be
with making another fashion haul.
In order to keep prices
low and profits high
fast fashion retailers started
skimping out on everything
from the wages of the
people who sew your garments
to the quality of the
fabric and construction.
Everything from the way
they cut pattern pieces
to the zippers and buttons
they use is designed
to keep production costs
as low as possible.
- These frequent collections
also warp our perspective
on how much clothing is enough.
Yes, everyone wears
something to work every day.
- [Julia] At least we hope.
- But fast fashion retailers
want us to feel like
we need to go all in on
the latest TikTok aesthetic
even if the trend will already be passe
by the time our order arrives.
The pace of fast fashion
has escalated so much
that online retailers like
Shein now put thousands
of new items on their site every day
and the average American
buys 68 new items a year.
- We also throw away way more clothes.
Because brands cut so many
corners to keep prices low,
your clothes are literally
built to fall apart
and all the better for
fast fashion's bottom line.
If consumers buy into the idea
that their clothes are disposable
they'll keep coming back to buy more.
Who cares if it's so affordable, right?
- Well, it's not affordable
to the people making your clothes.
As Aja Barber writes
in her book "Consumed"
about the impacts of fast fashion,
the average garment worker can't afford
to buy the clothes she makes.
Retailers like Shein
regularly come under fire
for violating labor
laws in their factories
where garment workers put in 16 hour days,
generally making about 4 cents
per finished item of clothing.
- And it's not affordable
for the planet either!
According to the EPA,
Americans throw out over 11 million tons
of textiles every year.
That's five times what we
tossed out in the eighties!
Now, fast fashion makes up 8%
of the world's greenhouse gas emissions
in the cycle from production to landfill.
- Because the trend
cycles are moving so fast
and the clothing is made poorly,
your fast fashion likely can't be donated
or even worn for more than a few wears.
It's just trash.
The low prices of fast
fashion obscure the true cost
to workers, consumers,
and the environment.
- But even if fast fashion wasn't bad
for the people or the planet
it can still be pretty
disastrous for your wallet.
In our episode about how
it's expensive to be poor
we talked about how
buying the cheapest option
can cost more in the long run.
And that's true here too.
- If you buy the average number
of fast fashion pieces a year,
about 68 and spend $20 per item,
over five years you will
have spent $6,800 on clothes,
maybe more if you put all those clothes
on a credit card you can't pay off
or bought them using a
buy now pay later service.
- If you return to the average number
of garments someone bought in the 1980s
you could even spend
four times as much money
per piece on higher quality items.
And over five years
you'll have spent $2,000
less on clothes overall.
And because you bought clothes that last
by now you've got just as many items
as the average fast fashion shopper.
- How can more expensive
clothing turn out to be cheaper?
Consider cost per wear
by dividing the price of a clothing item
by the number of times you'll use it.
A $15 dress you wear twice
works out to $7 each time you wear it.
Meanwhile, a $100 dress that
lasts you three dozen wears
comes out to less than $3 per wear.
Fast fashion seems more
affordable in the short term,
but even though it feels
like you're getting way more clothes,
you're getting a lot
less value out of them.
- So, what can you do instead?
First, buy less and buy better.
Building a wardrobe you love
is a marathon, not a sprint.
So take your time when you shop
and learn to check seams, hems, linings,
and other details that help you know
if a garment is built to last.
Higher prices don't always mean
the garment is better made,
but if you wanna splurge on
some higher quality items
you get more out of your clothing budget
if you buy fewer pieces per year.
- Buying less might mean you feel left out
when everyone else is having
their disco pants era.
But the whole reason trends
exist in the first place is
because clothing manufacturers
are churning out new items
and running ads and
pushing sponsored content
into your feeds to get you
to spend more of your money.
Remember, you don't have
to buy into every trend
in order to have personal style.
- My personal favorite
solution is buying secondhand.
It lets you divert someone
else's waste from the landfill
in the process of getting
you your new favorite fit.
And for special events or costume parties
consider borrowing or renting
rather than buying a fancy outfit
you only plan to wear once.
- And finally, treat the
clothes that you have with care.
Even if you already own fast fashion,
taking good care of your clothes
gives them a longer lifespan.
Read those annoying little labels
so you know when to
hand wash delicate items
or hang things to air dry.
- Watch YouTube tutorials and
learn how to do basic mending
like fixing a loose hem,
sewing on a button or patching a hole.
Visible mending techniques
that use colorful thread
or fun patches are also a
great way to update an old item
for a new look.
- Lots of shoppers say
they buy fast fashion
because they want to have fun
with their clothes without
spending too much money.
- And we get it.
No matter what your budget,
you deserve to love the clothes you wear.
But to get there, we all
need to treat our wardrobes
like treasures, not like trash.
- [Both] And that's our 2 cents.
- All this month, PBS is
releasing new digital series
and specials celebrating Earth Month.
- One in particular we'd
like to highlight is
"Above the Noises" new episode on e-Waste,
the term for when electronics
reach the end of their life cycle.
The episode covers their
environmental impact
and explores things
consumers can do about it.
- Check out the link in
the description for it
for the rest of PBS's
Earth Month playlist.
Thanks.
- [Julia] Thanks to our patrons
for keeping 2 Cents financially healthy.
Click the link in the description
to become a 2 Cents patron.
(upbeat music)